soit tu ouvres la porte on s'explique
gentiment sauf sa défense n'a compris 14
de ce mois mais je peux savoir qui vous
êtes
tu combats l'on trouve en profite c'est
pas un problème l'équipe de vénissieux
là je connais pas mais quand même c'est
[ __ ] mais c'est remettait dans la mer
tabu ley [ __ ] je te dis de pas traîné
je vais commencer par te refaire une
santé sous pas de raison
on n'a jamais dit le roi
avec l'api d'avoir son grand père voit
jamais connu ford a jamais connu sa mère
antoine avec en bonus n'est pas connu je
vais pas te mentir ces panneaux géants
prépa je suis pas faux si tu veux servir
sinon ils peuvent rester dormir sur le
canapé
je pense titres commencent par
rembourser 7 kilos d'argent quatre ans
j'ai touché touchés voilà l'arbre à
content tu penseras l'entraîneur s'est
mis aux voix tout est là dedans et il
cherche à gagner quoi au juste choqué en
france
je pourrais me dépanne façon j'allais
tout faire chier aujourd'hui vous est
donné le mot quoi 500 euros ils voient
bien sinon le dise où je bosse tient ici
qui vient tous les jeudis tu as
rencontré comme ça je pourrais y aura
coûté au père était jean lacoste et
gosse je manquais de repères j'aurais
voulu être plus proche de doigts
la petite plaque sur le plan parmi ces
crèches ou robert gerber maintenant les
pense tout pour sa prépa c'est combien
ça coûte ses produits s'est même prêté 8
cents à vous sur les économes d'imaginer
quoi c'est pas roland garros et tout ça
pour ressembler à ça c'était pour rire
l'intérieur et soit toujours été j'étais
pas attendu pour le démerder je passe
dans le toit pendant sentir
tu sais que tu as fait ça
mais bon si je vous dis tu sors il ya
les expendables